hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round two of this
year's Tata steel chess tournament it is
Wei versus GES Wei we haven't seen him
on the channel for quite some time now
but then you've seen him in the China
chess Kings where he defeated ding Lan
in the tie breaks of course that wasn't
classical but still very strong
performance and you can see he's doing
very well rating wise as well 2740 to to
Gish
2725 but he is facing a candidate here
Gish is one of the candidates of the
2024 candidates tournament and pretty
much every game that we show from this
tournament will feature at least one
candidate as there are five candidates
playing in the Tata steel and also two
reigning world champion so it's quite a
quite a beautiful event uh but uh that
being said let's check out the game it's
a it's pretty wild one uh where well
wayi just plays in his usual style where
everything is hanging everything nothing
makes sense you have no idea what is
happening at the board and GES has the
will find his way out of this mess so
let's check it out we have Pawn to E4
and gcash goes for Pawn to E5 we have
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to
C4 the Italian game is on the board and
Gish goes for the Joko piano asking we
are you prepared to go for the absolute
strongest move or will you settle for C3
well uh the we settles for the main line
of the Joko piano uh Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to D3 the Joo panimo variation
we have D6 and now Bishop to G5 so okay
you all know where where this is going a
H6 G5 and you basically give black the
attack or if white maybe has something
up it up his sleeve maybe white will be
the one attacking this game so H6 Bishop
to H4 Now Pawn to A6 preparing Pawn to
B5 and Knight B to D2 with have Bishop
back to A7 also a A6 is also important
to give the bishop the square on A7 uh
we have castles and now just Pawn to G5
chasing in away the bishop Bishop to G3
and now Bishop to G4 uh here gush sort
of followed in the footsteps of vishan
Anand as Anand played this game against
Anon demchenko and won a very nice game
in the world Blitz championship of 2017
but here gkes deviates with Bishop to G4
and okay H3 attacking the bishop Bishop
to H5 and now Pawn to B4 obviously a
very strong move uh and now again the
position is a known one known one pregar
headed against vidit in the Tata steel
rapid edition of last year H but vidit
continued with Rook to G8 however he
lost that game to pran but um it's not
that it was a bad move or anything it's
actually a top engine move uh if you
guys are interested top engine moves
here are queen to D7 Rook to G8 and
queen to C8 and Gish opts for one of the
three top engine moves and it is now
already as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so deviating from
the vided versus prar on the game but um
also deviating strong wrongly so okay
let's see this new game uh Queen comes
to C8 and now Pawn to B5 right away you
you will probably expect something like
Pawn to A4 maybe King to H1 or something
um uh you know that that makes sense uh
but we is not that kind of a player he
plays Pawn to B5 a captures Bishop
captures and now Gish just castles so he
unpins from this very nasty pin uh Rook
to E1 and now Bishop back to G6 so
making it a bit difficult for for D4 to
be executed maybe that E4 Pawn could be
attacked later on H but okay it is
defended nicely by the Knight and by The
Rook for the moment we have Rook to C1
uh and now Knight to H5 attacking the
bishop and also maybe hinting at the
Knight coming to F4 we have Bishop to H2
and now not Knight to F4 which uh well
many of us would play but instead Knight
back to G7 with options of maybe the
Knight coming to E6 and then to F4 uh if
needed or just um you know you know
having support for the advancement of
the pawn to F5 we have Pawn to D4 way
advances in the center puts pressure on
the E5 pawn and pawn to F6 G is just
playing a slow game uh waiting for his
chance to strike or maybe waiting for we
to overcommit as we is is a very
aggressive player uh so Knight to F1 uh
just REM maneuvering the Knight to usual
squares E3 or G3 Knight to E7 GES does
the same now he can chase away the
bishop with a move like C6 and now
Knight to E3 again a very very uh
straightforward play by by way you you'd
expect Bishop D3 defending E4 before REM
maneuvering the Knight but no he plays
Knight to E3 and he offers the E4 Pawn
now can the pawn on e4 be captured well
uh the engine says yes you can capture
it and it's even the strongest move
recommended by the engine H but I will
just show you what happens if you touch
the pawn if Bishop captures on e4 then
the idea is Knight G4 you open up an
attack towards the bishop and you go
after the H6 pawn and as there's no way
to defend both you have to play Bishop
captures on F3 attack the White Queen
and after Queen captures now your F6
pawn and H6 Pawn are hanging you have to
play Pawn to F5 sort of tra try to trap
the Knight if Knight captures an H6 then
you attack it with the King but now
Knight captures on E5 white would
sacrifice a piece D captures Bishop
captures and this is the position where
he had in mind he would have the monster
Bishop pair this bishop would come to C4
he would have the Rook the queen ready
to attack uh it's a crazy position
that's objectively equal but of course
we knows what is going into however GES
not interested in that he plays Pawn to
H5 he wants to be the one attacking uh
hinting at Pawn to G4 so what can we you
do here well he again plays Pawn to C4
he it's like he doesn't care about
anything uh again he offers the E4 Pawn
but now it's not the E4 Pawn uh that uh
that is interesting to Gish but rather
the D4 pawn and now again if you play
Bishop captures on G4 then C5 was the
idea and now C5 uh is very strong that's
why C4 was played uh trying to open up
the C file towards that black queen and
it's hard to it's hard to figure out a
move for black here for example if you
capture here then D captures on E5
already Black's position is completely
shattered you lose the center your pawns
on the king side are Advanced and your
king will be uh well very much naked
here so instead gcash plays e captures
and D 4 and now again not Knight
captures on D4 where he never plays a
move you'd expect he plays Knight to D5
and okay it seems like he's going for
the Knight on E7 he wants to take it uh
and deliver a royal Fork maybe win the
black queen uh and as Gish stops that
now you're probably expecting okay now
he'll probably capture on E7 and that's
pretty much it and I'm going to show you
what happens if Knight captures on E7 is
played I might be exploring uh you know
a line or two extra then I would in in a
rapid or Blitz game but this is
classical and we have to show what the
position really hides so the idea is
that if Knight captures on E7 check
Queen captures and then you Advance Pawn
to C5 uh it's uh it's quite strong for
example if Bishop captures on C5 now the
only thing defending the bishop is the
pawn uh on D6 and even if you play Pawn
to E5 and after d captures on E5 yes the
queen is defending the bishop here
there's this very nasty Knight captures
an E5 move and after F captures Rook
captures attacking the queen and a
double attack on the bishop here Queen
to F6 puts pressure on the F F2 pawn and
now Rook C captures on C5 Queen captures
on F2 with check King to H1 and now even
Pawn to C6 kicking away the bishop
Bishop to C4 check Bishop to F7 blocking
and now Rook captures on G5 and now look
at this bishop captures on C4 H but
you're going to play Bishop to E5 put
pressure on the the Knight here and
after let's say queen to F1 check you
trade Queens uh White does not capture
but rather white plays King to H2 you
give up the queen and after Queen
captures on D1 you play Rook captures on
G7 with check forcing the king into a
windmill and now you just uh take the
Perpetual as there is nothing better
Rook G7 check Rook B7 check Rook G7
check uh and so on so this is uh one of
the possibilities uh after this um uh
Queen to d8 move if you go for Knight
captures um uh sorry if uh after this uh
Queen to d8 move and Knight captures on
D4 uh you go uh sorry if if in if you go
for Knight captures on E7 uh but in but
instead Knight captures on D4 was played
by way uh and now well now it's just
very hard he missed well it's not very
hard he missed one specific idea from
gkes and it's the only move that gives
GES the advantage uh but I'm pretty sure
now that I've explained to you why the
previous line was soos ENT now you will
have no problem finding the absolute
strongest move for gash while I give you
a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this uh incredible move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to C5 that is the move that
way missed and now uh the position is
very difficult because without advancing
this Pawn to C5 uh there's just no way
to uh seek any advantage here he went
for Knight to B3 to put pressure on the
bishop but now Gish just plays Bishop to
A3 and attacks The Rook here and again
You're Expecting Knight captures on E7
check there or moving The Rook there's
nothing better like Knight captures on
E7 check Queen captures and now Rook to
B1 okay you move the Rook but then
something like C6 attacks the bishop and
you can't go to A4 so what do you play
here you have to play C5 give up the
bishop and then after something like
captures and captures okay you will pick
up the Rook on f8 and after Queen to E6
okay captures and captur you will have
the uh two two pieces for for Rook uh
but still uh it's only it's only black
who will be playing this for the win
however not from Wei he doesn't go for
Knight captures on E7 uh he's adamant
about advancing the pawn to C5 and no
one is stopping him uh at that he plays
Knight captures on C7 the move from the
thumbnail and now well how do you react
to this of course the Knight has to be
captured Queen captures and C5 was
played and now Pawn to C5 now it's
Unstoppable uh but uh it's not uh well
it's not that impressive Bishop captures
on C1 by gkes uh C captures on D6
attacking the queen and the Knight and
now Queen to B6 a crucial move in
continuing this position as it puts
pressure on the undefended bishop on B5
and also puts pressure on F2 as The Rook
captures on A2 is coming so what can Wei
do now well he could move the bishop
with check Bishop to C4 check but the
problem is after King to h8 and okay D
captures on E7 Rook F to C8 is coming
attacking the bishop and even if you
capture on C1 while defending the bishop
now comes Rook captures on A2 and now
Checkmate is being threatened of course
Queen captures on F2 followed by Queen
captures on
G2 uh and uh there's just no good way of
stopping that if you play Knight to D2
uh then just Rook captures and C4 and if
Knight captures again you will deliver
Checkmate and if Queen captures you will
pick up the Knight on D2 and that's just
it you're up a full Knight with both
Knight and Bishop guarding that queening
square uh there is nothing to hope for
here W with white so after this queen to
B6 move way realizes that this is
impossible he cannot uh play something
like Bishop to C4 check which which sort
of seemed like the way to go he has to
go for D captures on E7 but now again
Rook F to C8 incredibly strong by GES uh
and now if you capture of course the the
bishop then Queen captures on B5 or if
you capture with the Knight so here E8
Queen check was played uh sort of the uh
maybe force uh gkes to play Rook
captures but of course there is no
reason for gkes to move the Rook away
from the C file uh instead he just picks
it up with the Knight Knight captures on
E8 we have Bishop captures on E8 and now
Rook captures on A2 first going for this
threat of Queen captus and Queen captus
on G2 Checkmate so Queen to D5 with
check King to h8 and now Knight to D4
stopping Queen captures on F2 uh but now
just Bishop captures on E8 there is uh
no more hope for for way here Bishop to
D6 is played uh trying to get that Queen
into the attack somehow if you can get
your queen here and capture on F6 then
of course anything is still possible uh
but here just Queen to A5 uh and he was
in this position un move 33 that way he
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here of course you don't
want to trade Queens but if you move the
queen then The Rook on E1 hangs and
that's it so your only move is to trade
queens and once the Queens get traded
off captures captures uh there's just uh
no no way you can play this position
it's just
um I mean you're down a full Rook of
course it would be silly to to even try
this uh so yeah after Queen to A5 we
resigned and a spectacular win for Gar
so again we have a uh like in the Alesa
game it's unclear whether Wei simply
mixed up lines or or did he
just hope that he would you know uh
remain triumphant amidst all all this
chaos uh it's hard to say because it's
way playing and he always plays like
this uh but yeah gush is incredibly
strong he calculates precisely and uh
well at least in this game it was not
possible to to play against gush in in
this particular fashion uh so yeah very
nicely done by both of them but it is
gkes who who wins the game so big
congratulations to him and I will now uh
mention what happened in the other game
so if you guys are not interested uh you
know stop watching the video now I don't
want to spoil the fun for anyone as I
will be showing at least one more game
from round two uh so these are the the
results of the game uh Abdus satov and
pral Drew their game Yan pomi drew his
game to juun so big result for nepo
drawing against the world champion and
much like her yesterday's game against
Anish giri it was also a grueling end
game
went deep the move well I don't want to
trick you guys I can even check how many
moves they played uh but here even
though it could have gone U well very
much differently okay it lasted 72 no it
lasted 80 moves what same as the game
against Anish really let me just
check
yeah J Eng really really playing
uh oh no against Anish it's
uh yeah 81 no 80 moves yeah same against
same as against Anish wow very
interesting uh but yeah against nepo in
the end it was even her who
was uh pushing for the win she was up up
a in a rook end game but of course it's
is just a draw but yeah incredibly
impressive I mean uh against Anish
against Yan pesi holding her own Anish
okay he tricked her in the end game but
still very very impressive stuff and you
can see that her rating definitely
doesn't do her justice 25 49 is way too
low for jeno and if she if she played
you know seriously in a couple of more
tournaments uh in in strong opposition
like this I mean she would be 20 26 2650
at least uh at least in my opinion then
you have Anisha versus vidit a draw Wei
versus gukesh the game that we just saw
okay gukesh won very nicely ala defeated
maulu also previous video do check it
out if you haven't really a Master Class
by Ala ding Len this was a pretty big
surprise to everyone uh drawing a game
with the white pieces to Alexander
donchenko sort of the underdog of the
tournament uh but yeah you know played
very strongly and the ding wasn't able
to figure anything out and uh the game
that I will show uh after this one is
Jordan F fores versus max vmer also very
interesting one but yeah tomorrow uh GES
got a nice win but tomorrow he will face
ding Len reigning uh reigning classical
world champion it's a big big
opportunity for him so we'll see how he
does I don't know if he has black or
white tomorrow let me just
check uh a Gish will be having White
against ding uh so yeah incredible
opportunity for him uh will probably be
checking out that game uh you know if if
it's not going to be a complete snooze
Fest uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Welsh fan Mark Henley Brennan Michael
mes Frank banner and the best content
maker for a contribution to my channel
um uh thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and sorry about me
having some throat issues it's uh you
know it's just the season uh what you
going to do uh see you
soon